E aí
oi oi
o
voluntariado não é caridade voluntariado
não é apenas uma linha no CV
voluntariado é acima Tudo parte fração
quem é que daqui já alguma vez
participam em algum tipo de atividade
voluntária um criado boa
em 2018 cerca de 700 mil pessoas
estiveram envolvidas em trabalhos
voluntários é um número bom certo
compararmos com o final do milênio
passado em 1999
1.7 milhões de pessoas portugueses
tiveram envolvidos em atividades de
voluntariado
e o que terá acontecido em 19 anos que
já nós temos perdido o milhão de pessoas
1 milhão de voluntários somente quando
os estudos continuam a comprovar a e a
mostrar os benefícios que trabalho
voluntariado de trás não só o indivíduo
como também a sociedade Será que daqui a
20 anos pelas contas Mas vamos ter
voluntárias em Portugal eu sou Lia Este
é o Wilson e nós somos voluntários a
tempo inteiro desde 2015
a palavra voluntário vem de uma de uma
palavra em latim quer dizer vontade
uma faculdade de querer mas querer o quê
é ser voluntário em mais do que ter um
coração bondoso que ir ajudar ser
voluntário é comprometermos com
organização com um projeto de uma forma
responsável e uma forma assídua mas
também com as suas regras é sairmos do
nosso tempo confortável daquelas regras
que que nós fizemos muitas vezes sem
pensar daquelas que nós não fazemos
porque não queremos porque não
concordamos é
servir os outros é ajudar os outros é
fazer a nossa parte
bom e quando nós fazemos a nossa parte
quando nós ajudamos os outros nós usamos
nossos talentos por isso o nosso Talento
é Nossa Arte e nós podemos dizer todos
somos artistas
e
se Nossa Arte o nosso talento e agora
aqui vamos pensar que um talento a pode
ser um grande seca a pode ser um grande
músico a mas também podemos pensar nos
talentos
É porque quando a ver aquela coisa de
mas eu não tenho talento nenhum
a sorrir saber sorrir saber dizer a
palavra certa na altura certa saber se
está instalado na altura certa e é com
esses talentos que nós contribuímos para
a sociedade
o e consegue imaginar um mundo em que
ninguém partilha também nenhum
e seria esquisito ninguém pode fazer
tudo é certo mas todos podemos fazer
alguma coisa e o que é fazer a nossa
arte partilhar Os nossos talentos servir
o outro é nós agirmos é sairmos de uma
posição que nós conhecemos no ocidente
confortável daquilo que nós já sabemos
fazer evento darmos a fazer outras
coisas
e quando nós ajudamos os outros
nós recebemos tantas coisas que muitas
vezes nem
nem temos noção
mas agora aqui rapidamente nós podemos
assim três coisas rápidas que quando nós
precisamos os nossos clientes para nós
servimos os outros quando nós ajudamos
que estão ao nosso lado que nós podemos
tirar nós podemos ter dinheiro mesmo em
trabalho voluntário nós podemos perceber
algum contributo com os nossos talentos
quando nós usamos os nossos talentos nós
podemos ter um sentimento de
a nossa descrição pessoal por mais
pequeno que seja um gesto
e ir com os nossos talentos Nós também
podemos
com que os outros fazer com que os
outros beneficiem dos nossos o exemplo
exemplos hoje aqui nesta sala temos luz
graças ao talento do também é dessa nós
temos uma lâmpada que nos proporciona
estarmos aqui Temos esta tecnologia mas
Steve Jobs Bill Gates Nós também
sofremos dos seus talentos e mesmo que
alguém diga mas eu não é bem assim de
onde ele vem não é bem assim quem é que
nunca usufruiu de um bom cozinhado de
uma mãe de um pai de um avô de um
familiar do amigo a verdade que
todos nós temos talentos e os talentos
não servem para termos guardar nos
escondermos os talentos servem para
serem partilhados
E aí e ao longo do tempo a nos sentimos
que nós podemos partilhar alguns dos
nossos talentos a e a verdade é que
quando nós precisamos um eles
multiplicam-se aparecem Os cogumelos e e
nós em 2010 sentimos a necessidade a a
vontade o desejo de partilhar um
bocadinho do nosso tempo e procuramos a
volta de Lisboa Cascais e era a nossa
Zona ou nós morávamos
associações trabalhassem com jovens em
comunidades mais divertidas e quando nós
usamos os nossos talentos artísticos
para trabalhar com estes jovens
e naquela altura nós não reconhecemos
mas a verdade é que aquela experiência
trouxe-nos
as ferramentas importantíssimas para o
nosso trabalho que vinha no futuro e e
nos apercebemos isto nosso Vivo e Claro
na nossa vida quando em 2017
e Nós aceitamos o convite de trabalhar
com uma organização não governamental de
emergência médica que trabalha em
situações de crise humanitária e esta
organização dependa sem por cento de
voluntários portanto imagine outra vez o
que era um mundo onde ninguém precisa
assistir os talentos ou ninguém
quisesses voluntário e
esta experiência foi a a coisa mais
louca e desafiando que nós já fizemos na
nossa vida e em que eu e o Ilda saímos a
Duzentos Por cento do nosso canto
confortável
sair do Canto confortável é mais do que
nós começamos um trabalho novo é mais do
que mudamos de cidade ou mudamos país ou
até mesmo estarmos no na Linha da Frente
com hoje em dia se fala muito né
e com nós começamos a trabalhar com ação
a dia em 2017 nós o primeiro país para
nós fomos chamados foi a Grécia nós
temos seis meses na Grécia e a realidade
como nós mostramos quando nós chegamos é
completamente diferente banho não diria
completamente diferente mas é bastante
diferente do que aquilo que se comunica
a comunicação social nos mostra aqui na
nossa casa nós vamos trabalhar com campo
de refugiados afegãos a a norte de
Atenas e hoje em dia nós ouvimos falar
muito feliz tão causa da grande crise
política que eles eles estão a viver
hoje em dia não é e da iminente crise
humanitária que é o que se diz na
conexão social mas a verdade é que já em
2017 milhares centenas milhares de
pessoas já tinham fugido do Afeganistão
e quando nós falamos refugiados o fundo
estão nós não temos a falar de três
quatro cinco pessoas que apanham barco
achar Europa nós temos a falar pessoas
que percorrem milhares e milhares de
quilómetros a pé virtualmente a pé mas a
Fato famílias que vem e com as crianças
pequenas estão Safari doses interface
grávidas depois dos 6 meses nós tivemos
a na Grécia Nós moramos por aqui no
Iraque nós conseguimos e seremos um
hospital a saída da cidade de mossul na
altura com nós chegamos a cidade de
mossul estava sob o poder do estado
islâmico e aqui a guerra que estava a
acontecer para libertação da cidade fiz
com que centenas de milhares de pessoas
deslocassem da sociedade e ter é sempre
a outra cidade outra zona mais segura
noutra parte qualquer direto muitos
deles também fugir na Europa
durante mais de um ano onde nós
trabalhamos na trabalhando naquele
naquele hospital
é nós
nós esperamos com famílias Foram
desfeitos pela guerra
e nos vimos viúvas com cinco seis filhos
nós temos crianças com estilhaços de
bombas
nós vimos os pais que viram seus filhos
e morrerão e vimos muitas pessoas
perderam braço ou perder uma perna
Oi e a verdade é que enquanto nós
estávamos aquilo que nós vivemos e
aquilo que nós sentimos nos vimos que
gestes pênis podem fazer a diferença e
nós vivemos lá
foi um sentimento de gratidão que ao que
não pode ser Fingida gratidão é um
sentimento que tem que ser vida e nós
vivemos nós temos que essas famílias
saindo da sua zona de conforto porque
eram obrigadas a elas não tem a opção de
escolha elas se não nas suas casas de do
bairro que eles cresceram e foram
obrigadas a viver pretendes numa região
em que no verão chega aos 50 graus e se
calhar nós aqui pensamos é para hoje tá
muito calor então que a 27° 2623 não sei
agora imagina tem dentro de uma tenda
com 50 graus e no inverno chegam a
temperaturas negativas
é de família já tem noção mas o impacto
que elas causaram a nossa vida realmente
o maior do que impacto nos cola na vida
delas nós vimos que a mudança é algo que
nós temos fazer os outros mas ela como é
que acontece nós nós vimos nós fizemos
nós temos a mudança possível ao isso
mudamos os nomes mais empáticos não diz
mais resilientes tem continuar trabalhar
vamos no hospital Nós Somos convidados
para a usar os nossos talentos
artísticos para irmos outro campo de
refugiados e aqui nós fomos a um campo
de refugiados sírios ao contrário dos
dos iraquianos com que nós trabalhamos
no hospital os cílios Não tem qualquer
perspectiva Não tem qualquer expectativa
de voltar para casa talvez porque a
guerra já durar muito tempo talvez
porque ele já sabem que é assim que a
vida é infelizmente é esse sentimento
que ele já tem mas a verdade é que os
Campo o campo dos Campos de refugiados
que existem pelo nós não queremos
refugiados sírios já estão estabelecidos
a 7 8 10 anos são famílias que passaram
de viver numa tenda Ok vamos aqui
vivendo uma tenda com 50 graus mas
passaram a viver em uma tenda para viver
numa casa de tijolo e cimento
alimentante crianças que lá estão
Jackson já nasceram em teste no campo de
refugiados Talvez para nós aqui a
distância quando falamos e falamos tanta
vez que me campo de refugiados seja ao
que está tão longe se calhar não nos
vamos toca de maneira especial mas com
nós fizemos este projeto artístico nós
vimos que estas famílias certa maneira
já perderam a esperança apesar de terem
certeza que podem continuar irão ter
aquele tipo de vida para o futuro já
perderam a esperança de lutar e tentar
tirar o melhor
bom então nós decidimos deixar uma
mensagem uma mensagem positiva uma
mensagem de esperança uma mensagem que
mostre que nós não temos que esquecer
nosso passado nós temos aqui aprender
que o nosso passado e fazer com que
nosso futuro seja diferente depois nós
temos esta actividade artística lá
naquele campo Nós Somos convidados a
neste caso Quanto mais desafiados a
pensar num projeto possa realmente fazer
a diferença naquele campo de refugiados
nós fizemos um mural temos um uma
pintura única mas no final daquilo
víamos desafiar para pensarmos no
projeto possa ser diferente possa
realmente fazer a diferença no total
daquela comunidade e então Nós pensamos
pensamos tem temos a desenvolver um
projeto Que idade tem no próximo ano em
que nós convidamos diferentes artistas
internacionais
iremos tudo correr bem pintar aquele
tempo todo com cores que no fundo essas
cores essas mensagens que certeza vão
trazer só mensagens de esperanças
mensagem de alegria mas eu também para
trazer vida para aquele E aí
hum hum
e enquanto Nós já estávamos a ficar
confortáveis no nosso canto por assim
dizer depois de mais um ano e pouco a
trabalhar no Iraque a nós mudarmos país
e vamos para o grande temos no médio
Oriente e vamos para a África quando
chegamos ao Uganda fones ponhas proposto
construímos um hospital para os
refugiados congoleses
é a realidade do Uganda é um bocado
diferente mandei um bocado as que
completamente diferente do que a
realidade dos Campos de refugiados na
Grécia a unidade nos normalmente com
dentes aqui Campos de refugiados estamos
habituados a ver a Campos que são
murados e mortal descansamos
conversações com a corante farpado com
militares a porta Mendes e esse foi
realidade que nós vimos na Grécia e
queremos no Iraque mas no grande é
diferente no grande o o governo dados
uma porção de terra e uma fronteira
significativa e depois as organizações
dividem as famílias por pequenos pedaços
de terra só para terem uma noção aquele
tempo nós estávamos não era de todo dos
maiores Campos de Uganda e era do
tamanho da cidade Lisboa só o teu Campo
e com nós saímos do grandão se
misturando ao ano passado em fevereiro
2020 são a 150 mil pessoas e outra vez
volta pedir aquele não era dos melhores
Campos do Ganda
nós temos do Ganda mas o grande nunca
nunca vai sair nós
Especialmente porque o nosso filho
nasceu no lugar na vai fazer agora dois
anos mas isso é outra história
nós no início fizemos uma pergunta não é
como é que nós como é que nós não como é
que os outros podem iniciar Os nossos
talentos
e a verdade é que se nós temos talentos
e todos nós temos talentos por mais que
nós devemos não temos talentos nós temos
também nós usamos que ser temos talentos
não é e
nós quando estávamos no
buraco
a antes de seguir falta de fazer uma
pergunta
quem é que alguma vez já pensou que a
preserverança pode ser um talento nós
falamos aqui ali me ensinou algumas
ideias algumas ideias que constrói um
bocado aqui que é o talento não é mas
que alguma vez já pensou que fosse
durante a passam talento quando estamos
no Iraque
por questões políticas
aeroporto show
o Ian vocês podem imaginar o Iraque um
país em guerra não é nós somos
estrangeiros no momento e dorme são
estrangeiros estavam lá e as pessoas
pensam que é incerteza instabilidade não
sabemos que vai acontecer então a
maioria das organizações internacionais
saíram do país noventa e cinco porcento
dos nossos voluntários e naquela altura
nós tínhamos bastante vontades quase
cinquenta voluntários a trabalhar
conosco 95cm dos nossos voluntários que
nós temos aqui aumento saíram também
decidi sair eu não sou de imunização
disse ok só se estiverem dispostos a
continuar nós continuamos
bom e nós
significar e tentar fazer o possível
para ajudar nós vimos naquelas semanas
seguintes
podemos fazer uma diferença que nunca
imaginava que isso acontecesse durante
várias semanas nós somos única
organização a providenciar a serviços
para Os Saltimbancos e naqueles cinco
Campos de refugiados no Iraque
estavam mais de 85 mil pessoas e o nosso
hospital é o único de previdência água
serviços sete dias por semana e 24 horas
nós vimos como gestos pequenos podem
fazer a diferença e a única coisa que
nós decidimos foi
e nós não ficamos aqui calhar isso pode
Não não dá para a gente e por mais
lindos os outros outras Doutor princesa
acontecer esse pensamento Ok vamos
experimentar eu olhando para trás calhar
não foi cima utilizam-se tão bem pensada
e na verdade eu acho que não foi foi
mais uma visão mais emotiva porque
queríamos mesmo era ajudar e
nós vimos a mudança nas pessoas
trabalharam conosco nós temos médias
temos a formar cientistas
locais e de que antes trabalhavam
conosco e eles sentiram fazer uns partes
deles porque nós ficamos com eles em
frente ao desconhecido Vimos a mudança
também nas pessoas estão mas a servir o
que não não sentiram afastadas de
esquecidas não sentiram a nossa sentirão
como que como se não fosse nada é nós
sentimos que podemos fazer a diferença
ali e mais do que providenciar os
serviços de saúde era o facto de nós nos
importamos e estamos lá e quando digo
nós não é por causa do rio da Lia mas
era por causa de todo o o feriado com a
nossa organização e facto de nós estamos
ali para servir e quando Estamos
envolvidos com este tipo de organizações
não é por causa de uma pessoa duas
pessoas mas eu acredito que é o
sentimento que existe dentro e ajuda de
a de nós nos negamos a nós mesmos para
servirmos nosso próximo faz com que de
certa maneira nos sintamos uma pressão
dos nossos pares Mas é uma pressão
positiva últimas estão positiva não é
eu ia nessa altura nós vimos a 1
o que não é o fax Nós temos muitos
talentos faz a diferença mas eu facto de
como nós usamos nossos talentos
e
é que hoje agora quantos de nós estamos
disponíveis para sair da nossa cadeira
comfortável quantos nós estamos
disponíveis para usar o nosso talento
qualquer que ele seja para fazermos a
nossa parte
os talentos escondermos
o meu Deus multas para quem não tem para
nós Talvez mas se calhar é só para nós
dizemos que os temos não é E aí
e o que é importante e o que nós vivemos
é que
a usar os novos talentos
bom é visível quando é para servir nós
somos testemunho daquilo que nós fizemos
mas também é importante agir quando o
aeroporto de fecha e todos os outros vão
embora no final do dia o que importa
o que realmente importa não é o nosso
talento o realmente importa não é Nossa
experiência
e na verdade o que realmente importa
a participação é
E aí
[Aplausos]